hello friends i'm alan and welcome to my
channel and if you don't already know me
i am a massive batman fan i have a
batman tattoo
i own a lot of money's worth of batman
memorabilia
i'm big into batman but i had a really
busy work week last week i was working i
feel like 9am to midnight
virtually every day so i slept in this
morning uh oh
my chair's having problems it's fine
it's you know wayne tech
active cloaking i slept in today because
it's a saturday um
knowing that it meant that i would be
sleeping through the wb games montreal
uh panel for dc fandom meaning that
since i have woken up and started my day
i have avoided
actually looking at any of my actual
news feeds on social media at
all because i really don't want to have
whatever this game that wb montreal is
working on spoiled for me so i'm going
to do a live reaction now
i am mostly excited i actually quite
liked arkham origins um because
the relationship between joker and
batman is like one of my favorite things
about batman and that game
focuses on that so specifically but i am
also a little afraid
that whatever this game is today that is
supposed to be being shown in their
panel this morning i think it was at 10
30
is gonna be like online or something so
i don't know what it is
uh i figured i would just react to it
let's do it i'm
yup nervously excited maybe
okay okay let's hit play let's do it
four minutes this is more than i
expected i'm stoked
in breaking news we've received reports
of an explosion
somewhere north of the city we're still
waiting for the police to confirm
if there are any victims this story is
evolving rapidly
please bear with us we were just really
loud boom there was smoke
and emergency services have confirmed
that they've discovered a body buried in
the wreckage
i'm already into it emergency
news an vehicles rocked gotham city
earlier today we're now
able to confirm that billionaire
philanthropist
bruce wayne is
i got goosebumps
oh what a cool tone piece it already
feels like nice and dark which is like
what i love about the awk series
if you're watching this i am i'm dead
it's gotta be a fake out mark okay
that's gonna be red hood
this message was automatically triggered
when i destroyed the cave and everything
it contained
we both know it won't take long for
gotham's criminals to realize the batman
is gone
are you serious i'm so curious if this
is actually true cpd
haven't trusted us since jim died
gotham will need its protectors more
than ever
i'm leaving you the belfry's base of
operations
some of the technology is outdated but
it has the gear you need and all of my
files
you've always had my back when i needed
you i know you'll keep gotham safe
good luck goodbye
[Music]
but what's his game
dude dub
oh it's red
okay
so if it's like sort of an extension of
previous games
like obviously this isn't made by
rockstar you know it's
it's wb montreal it's not going to be
necessarily the same thing
but you could swap between characters um
they've done that before so what is it
gonna be like do you choose one or you
jump between all four of them
consistently through the story
is it like the catwoman parts like how
how it gonna work
i mean that looks like awkward combat
yeah keep physics
[Music]
freeze is like one of the best villains
in the series is this like cannon to
that rest of the series
[Music]
no one
this is rumored for ages obviously
that makes me think batman's still alive
bruce wayne's still alive
he's just off doing quarter of the house
tanks
strikes you dead
[Music]
yeah yeah we like it yeah
yeah we we uh we are into this we are we
are absolutely into this
you say what platforms no it's just
gonna be a lot
i will watch the gameplay but um
we'll have the same thought exactly what
i was thinking this is one hundred
percent
batman faked his death for the court of
the elves um
yeah that is for sure what has happened
here
[Music]
[ __ ] i'm super into it okay let's watch
the gameplay
what is it was it what gameplay
hi i'm patrick redding creative director
on gotham knights hi
on behalf of the whole team at wb games
montreal
i'm really honored to give you a quick
look at our gameplay
elliot center is covered in ice
whatever's causing this
is localized at the top
we're gonna look at a short clip from
one of gotham knight's villain crimes
in a pre-alpha build
this mission is halfway through the mr
freeze storyline
and we're playing batgirl a dozen or so
hours into her character progression
interesting what does that mean like can
i choose
again like how do i choose which yeah
the quality doesn't look great let me
see if i can fix that
yeah why haven't we done that let's
rewind there you go that's better
is that a mysterious agenda isn't that
like his thing all of the game either
solo or into player co-op
cool he'll get it
cool i hope so robin's learned how to
access
the justice league satellite for
short-range teleportation
there are things you have to change
about a single player experience to make
it multiplayer i like the idea of having
a co-op
like a two-person co-op batman game but
has mastered some
more familiar techniques there are there
are compromises you have to make on a
single player experience like some of
the atmospheric moments could have
could be a bit hard by that but we'll
see
and developed a few new ones of her own
montoya here heard you're down there
having some fun fun's one word for it
just a heads up that chopper's under
orders to fire on anything that moves
inside
i feel like i'm not talking enough i'm
sorry people get mad if you talk too
much or too little with these videos so
they're really hard to make but
uh this one i am genuinely just so
caught up in what i'm looking at that
i'm not even thinking about the fact
that there's an audience there and i'm
sorry about that
this looks really cool get it
it's decise
that's what i'm here for okay so even
though it's called that still looks
really cinematic
but like how does the other player get
affected by things like that
do they just see the same thing i meant
to do that
i won't say a word
tours were still going on when freeze
came through
those poor people i love these
environments in the [ __ ] awkward
games
i like that this doesn't look that much
like a sequel approach each challenge
with their preferred style
that it looks fresh enough you know i
was having this conversation with
someone recently it was like
the arkham trilogy even though yeah it's
like four games and then there's like
all the spin-offs
um it's like it's such a good trilogy
does it need any more
games industry always keeps annualizing
things and making more or
turning things into franchises it's so
rare that we get like a neat trilogy
i was like i don't know it has to be
oh i love the combat song every game
could have this combat on that note the
arkham combat i love it
um but same token i would want it to be
fresh
this was pretty fresh i'm not loving the
um bars over their heads the levels but
maybe you can turn that off in the ui
i'd prefer not to have that was hoping
to see some gadgets there we go
that's cool
not the safest time to take the elevator
i wonder if the the frame rate hiccups
up because of the
the video this probably was pulled from
a stream
um the internet all because of the
footage it is pre-alpha though either
way
guaranteed they lead to freeze not
coming out till next year who cares
you got time if it will coming out next
month i'd be concerned wow the lighting
is really pretty
that's that's stunning i'd like hang
that weird
ice painting in a in a [ __ ] apartment
countless dead and the temperatures
still falling we need to stop this
now i mean no [ __ ] though
it's not kind of going outside about
this storm
almost there i don't know how i feel
about her voice acting
but that's okay i see the weather
machine
ready with the disrupter that thing's
drawing so much power
i think that one of the things i like
about playing as batman is that he's
real quiet
so that might be you know something i'm
not a huge fan of we'll see
i feel this records in place
it's charging is she carrying that in a
suit did i miss that how the [ __ ] are
you fitting that in there
there he is that was the best boss fight
is that what you're calling it
you don't want to be on the roof when
this disruptor goes off trust me
irrelevant i already have what i need
[Applause]
cool
see him having a health bar makes sense
the other enemies
it's probably for the co-op and i don't
love it
an important element of gotham knights
is that as the player increases
damage numbers fair foes keep pace
so confronting a villain like mr freeze
can be a very different proposition at
level 5
or level 15.
the kinds of attacks and defenses they
bring to bear
listen i don't mind a level system i
think assassin's creed adapted to it
well
i got them knights we're going to have
more she's saying some stuff i'm unsure
about though yeah
yeah you know
all right okay okay thoughts
that teaser trailer beautiful
loved it core of the owls stoked love
that story line
um positive batman's alive uh i you'll
probably get to play as him at some
point
the gameplay looks different enough from
the series and i'm happy with it
but yeah like i said some things that
caused concern for me
are very specifically
having a game catered to a co-op
experience and also a single player
experience sometimes doesn't work so
well
um that means it's probably going to be
very open world that means that
we might be able to do quests in any
different order he did just say
whether you're level 5 or level 15 um i
don't love that so i'm going to feel
like a large map where you can choose in
what order you want to do things which
concerns me for the narrative i could be
wrong this is all totally speculative
but that concerns me from a um
a uh you know how are you going to tell
the court of the owl story and how he
really gripped and what's happening
if that's the way that the game plays
which seems likely to me
um yeah i didn't love the damage damage
numbers showing up although the hippos
over their heads but you know
way way too much to say right now that
first teaser i love i love the tone i
love that they tried to make the chord
of hours really creepy
so i would currently say i think my
concerns were valid
not 100 sold okay i'm 100 sold i'm going
to play it
but like i'm not positive this is going
to be you know um
exactly what i want uh co-op i was i was
into until they you know
elaborated on it a little bit and i
still don't know what rocksteady's
announcement is other than it being
suicide squad but i don't know what that
looks like either are they gonna be
similar they're also going to be co-op
probably
no i'm scared uh thank you guys for
watching i hope this was at all
interesting i will see you guys next
time bye